[Music]
on today's show i have a special guest
ryan mickler from the order of man
podcast is here to talk about
masculinity toxic masculinity manliness
raising sons raising daughters being
married how to be a better version of
you stay tuned
[Music]
yo what up what up this is john with the
dr john deloney show
so good to see you and hear you order
i'm not doing either of those things but
i hope you are doing so good so good i
have been out for a few weeks and it is
fantastic to be back i've been missing
everybody
of course uh kelly didn't even bother to
show up today jenna's here it's so good
to see you jenna james is here as always
and by always i mean
always 2022 is gonna be all positivity
towards james child's way
you look great
did you have a good holiday i did
excellent and you
ah
you sound a little
like you're getting over something
i don't know why we gotta talk about
that
it was it was a hard break but we're
back jack
my uh
little
heart rate variability my heart rate
variability got so bad over the break
uh yeah it wasn't great but now we're
back now we are back in better than ever
i don't know what that means
probably not but hey listen today on
today's show our first show back
dude i
am so excited we've got a great guest um
we're gonna have an interview today with
ryan mickler from the order of man
podcast
ryan is a veteran
he has worked in the financial industry
he's got four kids three sons an
incredible little daughter he's been
married he has
run the gamut and he started about seven
years ago uh order of man podcast just
having conversations about how to be a
better husband how to be a better dad
and he noticed that his friends guys
were coming back from iraq guys who he
was working with were all having these
similar conversations with each other
and so he started podcast and it has
become one of the biggest podcasts in
the world and i'm so grateful that he
came to nashville spent some time with
us on our show we talk about toxic
masculinity what that actually means
what masculinity is raising sons raising
daughters how to be married
talk about guns we talk about hunting we
talk about everything all of it and um
talk about difference between
vulnerability and
you know vulnerability versus humility
versus honesty we talk about everything
it's a great conversation um maybe a
great conversation for
couples to have let's do together be
great conversations for
uh
parents and their kids to listen to so
stay tuned i'm glad you're here stay
tuned for my conversation with the one
and only ryan mickler
how have you lived in maine
uh almost three years no two and a half
years who took you there
adventure really yeah that's it my wife
and i um and our four children uh lived
in southern utah
and
i just went to southern utah where did
you go stunning where did where where i
flew into was it st
george yeah i flew into vegas and i was
doing an event there and i drove up
through i'd never been there did you go
to zion
maybe the national park you would know
it no i didn't go to zion okay it was
it's amazing one of those beautiful
places i've ever been red rock
everywhere this is a great time of year
so
i mean it was just stunning yeah
so we we lived in hurricane okay which
is at the base of zion national park
yeah just outside just 15 minutes from
st george okay so and that's where
people usually when they make a big life
shift and say i want to go i want to go
have adventure they go there they go to
st george you always they don't get
their name yeah so what took you to
maine so i i went up there you were
commenting on my origin boots and jeans
um my friend pete roberts is the founder
and owner yeah origin the dude's like an
american hero man he's incredible yeah
incredible is he for real
for real and
yes but in what sense are you talking
like he's like he's one of the best
people on the planet every single person
i've ever met who's talked about that
guy has said he's one of the best people
on the planet and then he oozes
i think that i can help america he does
that like that is that's a it's not a
that's not a play that's not a play
that's not marketing that's not brand i
mean he is a marketer that's his
background marketing but he's got so so
he's good at he's got to sell his
product but yeah yeah he's good at it
but he believes it man he believe and so
much so that because we talk just about
every day yeah and i train jiu jitsu
with him and everything else and so
you're jiu-jitsu guy too i've been
training for a little over three years
man
you trained jujitsu i did for years and
i haven't i haven't in a while yeah i've
been in a long embarrassing life it's so
weird because i really love jiu jitsu
but i'll be gone you know for a week or
two even even now you know i'm out of
town for three days
i'll go back and i love it and it's
still hard at times to go back in but i
love it yeah
so anyways um yeah so i knew pete he
invited me up to one of his jiu jitsu
camps
and i went up there and just fell in
love with the area my wife and i had
been talking about maybe making a move
and just kind of adventuring and seeing
the scene in the country a little bit
so i i was showing her videos and
pictures he's like yeah it's fall in
maine it's beautiful let's go back in
the winter right so i'm like okay so we
did pete invited us out there and we
stayed with
uh he's got a little airbnb above his uh
his dojos jiu jitsu dojo
and uh my wife and i went out there and
she fell in love with it so we did the
only
you know logical thing you should do
which is buy a house absolutely so that
was my second visit to maine it was her
first and she got a real estate agent
i'm like wait what you got a real estate
agent she's like yeah we might as well
look i'm like okay
and we looked at probably i don't know a
dozen houses maybe not that many and we
came down this this road
and saw this big beautiful house on the
corner i thought it was like a bed and
breakfast or a motel or something
and uh our real estate agent pulls in
there and before we even even get in the
house i was like we'll take it
and i'm like well like yeah hold up yeah
yeah we might want to see it you know
and uh so our real estate agent said
that that they were entertaining uh
backup offers they already had an
offering on the place this mike keeps
creeping on me here
um
so we put it back up so we went inside
and i saw the barn it's got this huge
four or five thousand square foot barn
and i'm like we'll take it done man yeah
and so we went and saw the rest of the
house and the people that owned it
before us did a beautiful job remodeling
it and restoring it to the way it would
have looked in the early 1900s
and so yeah we put an offer in on it and
then spent the next six months you know
getting our financial fares in order
getting the kids packed up getting our
house packed up and then drove to maine
it's funny we actually drove before we
even closed on the house we drew i told
the lady we were buying it from like
okay we're driving here's where we're
going she's like yeah just stay in the
house until we close i'm like i don't
know i'm like oh man what if we like
what if we move up here you know spend
all that money and time packing and then
she like backs out of the deal or
whatever and we and we've become
actually friends at this point the the
original owner
yeah wow man what a crazy adventure my
wife and i did something similar not
quite as crazy but we're from texas to
nashville just said it's time is that
right and we've got two little kids and
if we're gonna do it let's do it and
let's go have an adventure and it's
how's it been it's been great when was
that
four years ago now okay three and a half
years ago
not too long before right yeah yeah just
if it felt right i think more people
need to do that absolutely like you
gotta cut ties and and go find out who
you are and what you're about
and you've got it it distills your
values down real quick yeah well and and
you know a lot of people
they're they're you know i've had a lot
of people say well you know i wish i
could do that i've i really wanted to do
that and i wish i could do it and but i
have friends and i have this and yeah i
had all that stuff too i did too man i
had a group of guys i hung out with
every monday night for like 20 years
you do it right and you can always go
back actually that's what i thought i
thought when we moved to maine i thought
we're gonna be out here for a couple
years two three years and then um
after that we'll just move back home
like we'll have our adventure i don't my
wife i was talking with her um in the
spring and that's her that's her time
because the garden and the bees and she
does a lot of homesteading type stuff
and i said what do you think
are they yeah
it's like what are you thinking about
being out here she's like i'm never
moving back to utah wow
yes her family's all there so they all
kind of scattered and that's why we even
contemplated moving and then as soon as
we left they all moved back
so i thought for sure i thought maybe
it's us no it's not us it's you yeah
it's me it's not her
it's not her and it's not the kids
that's right it's like it's you know
anytime hey do you want to come back
like if ryan's busy it's okay like if he
has work he doesn't have to come
so you you've
um tell us about your previous life you
were in the service how long are you in
yeah um
eight years i was in the national guard
okay so i did uh did eight years the
last two years of my eight were spent um
activated i was i was deployed to iraq
in 2005 through 2006
uh in ramadi which is where jocko i know
he's yeah yeah yeah you guys did an
event together um so as an armadi 2005
2006.
and you know i was doing other stuff at
the time because it was national guard
up until that workup and and uh i was
doing real retail management okay so
clothing buckles journey shoe stores
yeah doing all that very cool i came
back and changed changed courses quite a
bit so you come back and then what then
what happens so
my wife and i because i was newly
married when i left iraq i think we were
married for about like six months or so
oh wow that's crazy um that was a
surprise deployment or did you know it
was coming
i didn't know it was coming you know
there was a likelihood that we would
sure and so my section chief calls me up
this was um
this must have been the day before
thanksgiving yeah in 2004
yeah 2004 he calls me up he's like hey
we're being deployed
i'm like why like
could you have waited a day or two to
tell me and so he's like well i could
have but like i felt obligated to tell
you as soon as i found out so
i i went
uh trish and i my wife and i were in uh
in california at the time
she went back to utah to see her family
i stayed because i had black friday so i
was going to go just spend the day in
utah so i drove up there we're sitting
at dinner thanksgiving dinner
and i guess i'm off a little bit because
i just get this news i hadn't told my
wife yet and my father-in-law no joke
says what's wrong with you did your unit
get deployed or something
oh man and he had no idea i don't know
why he would say that he said a weight
on you huh must have yeah and i said uh
in front of the whole family uh
including my wife who i hadn't told yet
um actually yeah i am wow
so yeah i left and then uh
you were asking me what i did when i got
back yeah so we decided we didn't want
to move back to california and do the
retail stuff so on a on a leave while i
was over in iraq
my father and mother-in-law introduced
me to
a financial advisor he was looking for
for two new advisors at the time so
actually took all of my licensing my
study materials for insurance and
investment exams back to iraq with me
and then when i got back i took the
exams and started down that path wow
yeah man and then what got you
solely over time
you got interested in talking about men
and just looking around i guess you got
little kids hold your kids i've got 13
i'm gonna mess this up 13 11 8 and 5. oh
man you got a gang yeah you got a good
crew man yeah that's awesome um so you
got interested in i got a 12 and a 6.
okay yeah um you got interested in
looking around your communities and
saying what is happening
yeah no
tell me how you got there i wish it was
like that okay that would have been way
better okay tell me how you got here for
me it was like what is happening with me
i suck at this okay at being a dad being
a dad at being a husband at being a
business owner like i just wasn't
getting it yep
um and then my wife and i actually um
not long after i got back from iraq we
actually went through a separation
trying to this mike's being a little
funky with me today
um
yeah so my wife and i went through a
separation and and we eventually
reconciled and you know now we're
happily married we have four kids
but uh
i started talking with a lot of guys
about a little bit about my situation
didn't have a dad growing up went
through the separation with my wife
and i mean i
story after story after story of guys
who felt the exact same way who had had
the exact same experience and so
i had started doing podcasting with my
financial planning practice huh
so that was uh
i enjoyed the medium of podcasting but i
was done with the financial
conversations so i said you know i'm
going to pivot and i'm going to start
talking about some of these men's issues
because i want to talk with guys that
i'm inspired by
so i can look selfishly so i can learn
and i don't really have any value to add
to these guys so maybe if i make it a
podcast and i can tell them i'm going to
promote it to my audience who's like my
mom
you're right yep you know i didn't tell
him that hey i only have one person
listening but i will promote it to her i
promise you
uh
and so you know the rest is history that
was
almost seven years ago wow crazy and and
now you've i mean it's caught fire
there's there's totally millions of men
saying dude let's let's have this
conversation yeah it's not being had
right well yeah and you know like
there's a lot of things that we've done
right for sure um but i think the growth
of what we've done is more a testament
to the fact that nothing like this is
out there and men want to have these
conversations and
up until relatively recently you know
we've been very communal in nature men
organizing in tribes right and and we
just don't have that anymore outside of
uh military services a lot like that
foot football sports competitive sports
is a lot like that and then you know i i
played football in baseball in high
school but i wasn't good enough to
progress past that yeah so that went
away yep then i went to the military
well that ended yeah so then you know
you don't have anything yeah so you
talked about you didn't have a model
tell me about growing up
yeah so my dad and mom split when i was
about three years old okay um you know
my dad
he's a good man um he made him he made a
lot of mistakes um he got into drugs and
got into alcohol and uh unfortunately
know that relationship didn't work out
we always had a relationship and um
unfortunately he's passed away now
but uh yeah my mom got remarried
a couple of different times and one of
my step-dads was an alcoholic never
abusive but an alcoholic and
never really liked him i don't know why
i look back i'm like why didn't i like
him i don't know why he's just like i
didn't like him yeah so we had a hard
time uh and then i had another
stepfather who was um verbally and
emotionally abusive never never really
directed at me but more towards my mom
and my sister
uh and and the way that ended was was
wild that ended with
my mom and me and my sister getting in
the bronco
that he had um disabled he had i don't
know i don't know exactly what he did i
think he took the battery the cable off
the battery the terminal
um and so my but for whatever the the
truck wouldn't start she's like getting
the car we're leaving the truck wouldn't
start and she popped it and knew exactly
what to do so i think it had happened
before wow
and so she starts to back up well he
runs out of the house and tries to close
the garage door she crashes through the
garage door
how old are you um
15
15 16 years old
and we're driving down the road and he's
running
on
by the side of the vehicle on the
passenger side and he's like banging on
my window
and i did the only thing i really knew
to do like i just punched the window i
hit it once and i saw it like kind of go
and i hit it again
and it just shattered on the ground and
we
ended up going to st george yeah
uh
and
he he was like he the my stepfather was
checking all the hospitals because you
know i punched that window and my hand
was kind of mangled and bloody and stuff
i still got the scars to show it but
yeah i didn't have a great great example
yeah you know so when i became a dad a
husband first and then a father it was
like
i don't know what to do yeah i was lost
and you find what i find with most men
is they
know exactly what
sucked about their childhood and they
start to replay it yeah that's the only
picture that god i know and isn't that
weird you find yourself saying stuff or
doing stuff and you're like what are you
you know what i mean you know because
you hate it but it's all you know yeah
and it's all your body knows really yeah
it's yeah it's it's by things so
getting into so you talk about
men masculinity which is
here's
we talk we're talking offline
about charting a third course here yeah
when i hear the word masculinity so
i spent years and years
in grad school and counseling so i hear
a lot of toxic masculinity that that
word right yeah
masculinity's destroying everything and
it's things that aren't even
anthropologically correct right
um that we just made it up a few years
ago right and then you get the other
side which is
what i would consider equally damaging
is this almost
celebration of neanderth of just
complete idiots
yeah and i i i struggle with with
finding a path in the middle here and it
looks like you have so walk me through
what how would you describe how would
you define masculinity for folks well
this is really important because you're
right you hear a lot of things like um
well you said toxic masculinity uh
tyrannical patriarchy you know down with
the patriarch you hear things like rape
culture
you know things that aren't
related to that are called that you know
it's kind of weird and
really really what i what i see it being
is is a
a movement to lump all masculinity in as
toxic or harmful or destructive so the
american psychological association came
out with a study
uh that at the end of the day if you
root everything away they basically said
that the attributes that we would
normally consider masculine by nature so
i think it was competitiveness dominance
uh maybe aggression
and stoicism are inherently harmful
well they're not yeah and
and when people say toxic masculinity i
know what some people are saying i know
they're saying what what's again some
people are saying that some masculinity
or if you take it to the extreme it can
be toxic i actually don't disagree with
that but i don't use that term because
it's
what are we even talking the fact that
we even need to sit here and define it
is is why i'm not going to use that with
that term because i don't think it's
used in the right
context and i don't think it has the
right motive behind it so so let's let
me say this
and i'm going to set the record straight
here masculinity is
amoral
it's not good it's not some people say
oh mask we need so good no it's not good
it's just as it is it is what it is yeah
yeah you know we have i was talking with
my son i told you you started a podcast
and we were talking about testosterone
yeah and i and i read up on a lot of
this because i want to stay in the know
and um you know
young young boys
fetuses babies newborns even in utero
are introduced to higher levels of
testosterone than our female
counterparts
and that changes us biologically
physiologically it changes who we are
and it causes us to
um have certain characteristics um
secondary sex characteristics like we're
bigger we're stronger we're faster bone
density muscle mass
but also the way that we behave in the
way that we interact with the world
and and it's amoral it just is is it's
how we utilize it and that's what i call
manliness gotcha so a man
can harness his masculinity for
productive outcomes that's somebody
who's acting like a man anything else is
male you can be a male you know that's a
that's a that's a biological birthright
right you're either a male or you're a
female right
then you have masculinity and how you
use your masculinity those
characteristics
caused by the hormones flooding through
our bodies is what determine if we're
being manly or not
so manly for you is not a pejorative
mainly for you is like it's a
that is a thing to aspire to kind of
like i hear i you know working with kids
there's a lot of
fathers
fewer dads right yeah they can father a
kid right but becoming somebody's dad
that's a different thing right so
there's a bunch of people who can be
male sure
manliness
when applied appropriately looks like
what it's the next level uh let me say
what it's not it's not you know wearing
a flannel shirt and and chopping wood
and disagreed yeah
i'm not saying you shouldn't okay come
on man it's it's not having a beard
again i'm not saying that you shouldn't
listen
i haven't shaved like in 11 months this
is all i got man
uh it's been probably like 11 minutes
for me hey dude
yeah jiu jitsu got in the way oh did it
or my beard got in the way of jiu-jitsu
yeah
um
yeah so
people say well you know it's it's going
to the gym no no no i mean strength is
important
but it's how you use the string
you know if you if if you go to the gym
and you're jacked and you're and you use
it to beat people yeah okay that's not
being manly
i mean you might have some masculinity
in there because you know you're you're
strong and you're big and you have those
those hormones but that's not being
manly no i don't think anybody would
suggest it is yeah
uh but but alternatively if you witness
a car accident and you're able to pry
open a door with your muscles and pull
somebody out of the car because you're
exhibiting bravery courage risk-taking
and the physical strength to be able to
deal with it that's manly behavior
so manly manliness is it's a character
it is it's developed it's earned it's
almost something practiced right well
that's the best way to get better at
anything you can't just be manly like
you have to actually practice it so a
lot of times people say
they'll say to me um
you know i nobody needs another man to
tell him how to be a man no that's the
furthest thing from the truth i need a
picture of what this looks like that's
exactly opposite yes reality yes so my
sons i've got three sons i've also got a
little girl
and they they need instruction yes
if they don't get it
then they have they have the potential
of going off course well see and i'll
i'll even go one step further they will
get it it will be from you or from
somebody they'll get an instruction
manual it might be faulty that's it yeah
maybe they will pick one up yeah and so
i love there's a i think it's maybe an
old adler quote an old psychologist
quote said i thought i could take away
somebody's depression anxiety and they
would be well i found they were empty
that's who they were i had to give them
my tools to learn how to practice to be
live a life of joy live a life of
relationship of connection or whatever
right similarly i can choose to teach my
son what a man looks like and here's
what value looks like and there's a
character looks like
or not
and somebody else will fill that vacuum
right and so he's going to use his
masculinity for
destructive for gain yes which becomes
yeah yeah but again and that's where
people say well see that's toxic
masculinity look i understand what
you're saying i don't disagree but i
don't use terms that are designed or at
least hijacked to paint all masculinity
as toxic that's right and i think we're
that that's i mean that's one of my core
missions here is we've got to chart a
third wave of instead of brushing
everything sideways right i mean with
one one one swipe right yeah um okay so
this is just me talking i
i look back at my childhood self my dad
was a homicide detective swat guy he was
a bad dude and he quit halfway through
my childhood and became like a minister
and
a hardcore dad he learned and my mom
wasn't she didn't do any no college or
anything until she was 40s in her 40s
and then she now she's a got a phd she's
a professor really so i grew up with
this with this wild
this wild
set of examples ahead of me which were
great yeah and i
also struggled
mightily with being what i would call a
masculine poser i i followed pantera
around i went to every show you can
imagine you know what i mean i played
high school football and i was i joined
mma gym like back before i mean own the
in the ken shamrock yeah and the oog
yeah and i
[Music]
i talked a lot of knowing i ran my mouth
a lot and i didn't have a
what i understood to be a picture of
what this actually looks like applied
right and
when i got married when i got out of
college when i got married when i
started i was a high school coach for a
while
especially what first you coached
i was a basketball truck basketball you
got it
let's be honest i was a track coach and
i did something
yeah i wasn't a great coach
we had a blast
it didn't make sense to me until i was
staring across the table at a wife who
is saying i don't know if i can keep
doing this with you um i didn't know
what this was until i had a kid and i'm
35 at this point man i got a doctor i
think i'm all smart i don't know what
this looks like
a child maybe i was 32. so
how do you bridge the gap between all of
these pseudo pictures if you will
and that application because man i've
gotta we have to do a better job of
getting upstream and teaching people
right before you're staring at your
child what being a man looks like yeah
before you're staring at your wife but
it's almost
equally challenging because you can't
really know what you don't know until
you're in the game right you can't and
that is one of the hard things i mean
you can get out ahead of it and realize
and you know i think there's one key
factor that really makes a male a male
and there's a lot of different ways that
we show and exhibit it but there's one
key factor and it's purpose it's meaning
and that's found through service to
others
so the frame i work best in frameworks
like when i have the framework in front
of me i'm like got it okay so the
framework for
male to man is to protect provide
preside okay protect protect yourself
your loved ones and those who cannot do
it for themselves
provide mentally emotionally physically
spiritually for you and your loved ones
and then preside to lead to help others
get to a place they could not have gone
on their own
that's the framework that i use and it's
not just the framework i use there's a
book called manhood in the making by
david gilmour and he
researched different tribes and
different cultures throughout much of
time in history and he found that all of
these tribes and cultures had a striking
similarity between the way they view men
what is manliness
and and what he said was protect provide
procreate
um i don't necessarily agree with
procreate defining you as a man because
i know plenty of guys dead father thing
right well not only that yes i didn't
even consider that where i was going
with it is that i know guys who can't
father children biologically they can't
do it i don't consider them less manly
just they biologically or medically or
physically aren't able to do that right
so um
this is why so many guys
hit that wall that you're talking about
like you and i both hit it when we get
married and have kids because what is
that responsibility yeah
right if you don't have any
responsibility you can't be a man
there has to be purpose to your life
there has to be meaning
and that's why we usually find it
in marriage partnership with a woman
because now we have somebody to provide
and protect for and or our children the
same thing but but you can you can
create that outside of marriage
absolutely well and and it goes back to
that vacuum if you don't create it the
world created for you which is why you
get pornography while she got um
i'm in the gym every day of my life but
there's people who go in excess right
there's there's every there's every
every excess you can imagine and get a
drugs all that stuff or people who work
90 hours a week and we give them a
million dollars to come a lawyer but
it's they're chasing that vacuum yeah
well let me give you a great example
about like gym culture so you know you
have a bunch of guys you're going to the
gym there's nothing wrong with that by
the way like that's a good thing yes
like we should be strong yes yeah
um but if they're doing it for selfish
reasons it's inferior it's not wrong
it's just inferior to doing it for
selfless reasons
so uh do you know who tim kennedy is
yeah sure tim shoes oh you do okay yeah
so you know yeah have you had him on the
podcast no okay he's honestly they don't
have that many beat buttons in there so
cool
he's a texan man he's a good guy he's
awesome yeah right so
um the guy's jacked yeah right he's
strong he's jacked um he trains probably
every day
i actually did a podcast with him i went
down to his place and i wanted to roll
with him but i know he was nursing a
shoulder injury yeah and so i didn't
really like push it i didn't bring it up
and i was like man i hope you get
feeling better next time we'll have to
roll he's like why don't we do it now
i'm like don't you have like aren't you
injured he's like that doesn't stop me
from training jiu jitsu i was like oh
well maybe i was just doing it so i
wouldn't have to fight
i'm glad to fight you one-armed that's
right
so um
anyways there's purpose behind
what he does right
and i i can't i wish i could remember
i said what like what is your life's
purpose or what is your your mission
statement because he had talked about
that and he said to to protect and serve
or something along those lines but it
wasn't just bull crap like it was real
it's legit
well that's why he trains
and because there's a significant
purpose and meaning behind it it gives
power to the actions that we
that we engage in it's deeper it's more
rich
right so you can have this guy who goes
into the gym who just wants to look good
naked or you can have somebody who's
like no i want to go to the gym i want
to get strong i want to train jiu jitsu
so if there ever is a situation that
arises i need to protect myself and
other people i'm capable of doing it
like which is the superior motive not by
my standards who am i to decide and
dictate what's important to you but i
promise that guy who has purpose and
meaning is going to find much more
fulfillment in his life absolutely or i
i now have switched gears because i'm
getting older i want to be able to roll
around with my grandkids right and that
starts now right that's a 30-year game
i'm playing now and i want to be able to
keep up with my son who's a freak in
nature big and strong and this is your
12 year this is my 12 year old okay yeah
yeah yeah i'm gonna have to work hard
now yeah what i mean and so
that gives me purpose and also hey can
you go get a wheelbarrow dirt for the
garden for my wife and kate can you help
me lift this those kind of things are
great right i mean i hear a lot in
culture like i think um
i think it might have been chris rock
sent me somebody sent me a chris rock
video and it said he was he's making the
joke that you know a woman is loved just
inherently but a man is only loved if
he's adding value and he was kind of
like mocking society's perspective of it
he's not wrong yeah and that's actually
not bad
like i find value in being valuable
[Applause]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john de loni show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get ten
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
delony
talk to me about masculinity and the
buzz word of the last few years with dr
brown's brought up
uh
how do men
express vulnerability and shame
well i don't like that term that word
vulnerability okay tell me about it
it's just a dumb like it's a dumb word
like
why would i want to be vulnerable like
what is vulnerability you're exposing
your weaknesses by definition that's
what you're doing yes why would i want
to do that
i would suggest it's because it it
relationally it helps you connect yeah
but that's not vulnerability it's called
humility
okay so tell me more
you're humble you know you're not
perfect you know you don't have it all
figured out and you're willing to share
you're willing to expose yourself to new
opportunities and
and new lessons and new experiences that
you can learn from but you don't have to
be vulnerable to do that because i think
we're just making it something greater
than it really is is it is there is
there is a semantic difference it may be
okay i mean it could be some people
might hear that say oh it's just a
semantic difference
i choose to look at it that way yeah
because i think vulnerability does
represent weakness by definition yeah
and no that's what it's me saying
you could hurt me right i'm going to
tell you that i'm not being a good
husband and i'm sorry right and that's
just being humble humble okay yeah so
i'm not gonna and there's also times
where it's not appropriate to
be vulnerable
in ramadi it's not helpful yeah or if
i'm faced with another violent encounter
on the on the road like like i can't hey
you know i'm not really
capable of defending myself can you you
know take it easy on me yeah like that
would be okay he's vulnerable right or i
would never leave my door open
uh in the middle of the night and not
set the security alarms and not have the
lights on and just say hey
criminals welcome like that's
vulnerability okay
okay but but humility on the other hand
is saying okay i want to defend and
protect protect my house if we're going
to use this analogy i want to protect
and defend my house so i need to be
humble enough to know that it's not
perfect and there's areas that i need to
shore up and i need to get the cameras
and i need to replace the batteries um
and this is an area that that could
be an actual vulnerability so i need to
be aware of that
so that's
that to me sounds like integrity being
honest
well integrity is not honesty though
either what is integrity integrity is
your thoughts are aligned with your
actions okay so you could be an evil son
of a gun and still be an integrity
because i'm just being who i am
your your beliefs are aligned with your
actions are aligned with your beliefs so
take a terrorist for example
somebody who thinks that their their
purpose on this world
is to to
uh kill innocent people who don't
believe like them
and that's their world belief that's
their belief about life and the
afterlife and then they go do it that's
a person actually yeah that's living
with integrity huh
very well said so that so integrity
could go either way
so i'm i'm trying to get below humility
which really means being able to look in
the mirror and tell the truth to
yourself that's that that actually is
good i like that or being able to
humiliate and again i have never thought
of that until just now
so i'm processing this in real time
i've never thought
do we just over
do we have too many words and over
sensationalize some very core life
principles tell the truth tell true to
yourself if you're not being a good
husband tell your wife i'm not doing
good at this and i need to get better at
this not even i need to but here's how i
will i'm going to right or here's how i
will yeah
like like
here's a plan here's a plan yeah because
nobody wants to hear somebody complain
and your wife certainly doesn't want to
hear her husband complain about all the
crappy things he does yeah what she
wants is she wants you to recognize some
honesty and then what are you gonna do
right and then actually do it yeah
integrity yeah
okay
so
the first time we were talking about
hunting before the show started
[Music]
help me as a just a man raising a little
boy a young he's not a little boy
anymore good grief he's a monster is
your sickness do you have a six-year-old
six-year-old daughter and then a twitter
son got it okay
and i'd fight him before i'd fight her
and uh oh yeah of course she's the
youngest she's the girl we actually uh
we start this week with jiu-jitsu for
her and i can't wait yeah she'll kill
her
so
my first time i ever went deer hunting
and i shot my first big deer
i had shown up to my father-in-law's
place and he's a pro-bass fisherman he's
just an out he's just an incredible guy
yeah
um this is your father-in-law my
father-in-law okay so he got you into
hunting yes okay yeah yeah yeah my dad
his
guns had a very i mean he was a tactical
guy
right yeah he was he was a hostage
negotiator like
you only pick up guns when things are
going down right and just hunting didn't
appeal to him and it's kind of like the
adage of like that's bad but you know
like once you're once you're shooting
people shooting deer it's a little
different well it's just i don't that's
that's right those are tools for work
here
my father-in-law hand is an outdoorsman
to the t's incredible man just i mean
he's an incredible outdoorsman and um
i had been a grad school nerd just nerd
nerd nerd i borrowed my wife's prius and
drove down to the hunting lease in texas
awesome
i appreciated that
how old was he at the time my son yeah
probably five okay got it four
shot an 11 point buck and shoved it into
the back of a prius
the grief i took on either side of that
conversation
which is i can't believe you're out
hunting i can't believe
who is the grown man would drive a prius
who was saying i can't believe you're
hunting
well whether it's my colleagues at work
or whether it's whoever
or can't believe
what is there to be said for i just like
the things that i like
and there's uh or a car gets great gas
mileage or yes it would have been much
easier to shove that thing in the back
of my truck that i drove yeah
but there seems to be a set of rules for
masculinity nowadays you mentioned a
couple you gotta have a funnel shirt you
better have an axe on your car you
better have an overland drive you better
wait and all those things are awesome
right
yet i there's a uh millions of men who
have never been in a gym because they
make their high school team they don't
even know where to start with that and
they feel like if there's not if i don't
meet these rules
you know what i mean and so yeah how do
you line up that's not masculine that is
that's not that is
i
i get stuck so and in here
when you're raising a son
the tendency is
hey that oh
you know what i mean yeah hey that's not
a oh i don't know man you're into
master chef and he loves cooking
and
like well that
i want to i'm celebrating that dude i'm
gonna high five that yeah but cook like
take cooking i've got buddies who'd say
dude that's you that's not your job bro
that's you know what i mean that's
that's stupid i agree 100
cooking is not masculine or feminine
like what what make what about that
would make that masculine or feminine
there you go like there's nothing
nonsense art's another one yes
or or or any form of interaction
oh that's that's not it's not masculine
or feminine yes like it's just a way to
express yourself so walk how do i how do
i when i look at somebody and they say
is this masculine or not what's what's a
litmus test i can give
well it's the protect provide preside
okay all right all right so so let's say
okay so
i'll tell you what's not masculine
being or may i'll say manly just so
we're using the same words that we were
using earlier
um
being 30 plus years old yeah living with
mom and dad
playing video games and not contributing
to the household yes
that's not manly right like nobody
nobody in the history of the planet has
ever thought that is why because they're
abdicating their responsibility of
protecting providing and presiding yes
now
let's take a um i would even say that's
not even that's not feminine either
no that's just a leech right
of course yeah
um but let's take uh
let's take acting or or cooking
is that person protecting providing
president like if your son let's say
your son decides he's going to go to
culinary school he's going to start he
made my podcast this morning i said hey
i need i got out of the gym late and i
was like hey i need you to make
breakfast he whipped it up dude he's
already being manly then you want to
know why because he yeah maybe he's not
making money but he's adding value to
the household absolutely that's manly
behavior yes at 12 years old and it's a
gift that i give him that responsibility
of course why would you get handled that
that's right yes okay so
why
do we have a culture
millions of kids that we have stolen
from them
the
weight of responsibility and the old
vikas is the scaffolding like i'm going
to push you one step further than you
think you can go because i know you can
do it you're capable of more than you
are
stolen from kids
yeah because we're weak why well we
don't want to be here's why it's not
that we care about our kids i mean we do
but that's not what that's why we say
we're doing it you know who we care more
about our own little sad feelings yeah
yeah
you want to see my kids suffer yeah
right or i don't i don't want to have
that awkward conversation i've had my 13
year old and you probably have
experienced this too ask me some very
sensitive questions the other night
getting we're just having dinner dude
just
living her life and my six-year-old
daughter she's climbing into her chair
mom
how does the boy part get in the girl
part i was like oh we're gonna do this
right now we're doing it right now and
you should yeah of course you should why
would it even be a weird thing it
shouldn't but it is because of not
because the kid the kid doesn't know
he's he or she is supposed to feel
awkward about that they wouldn't ask the
question they learned it from us right
yes so so your kid asks you that
question
and what most people will do is say
oh well go talk to your mom or i'll go
talk to your dad or i'll tell you when
you're older
because they aren't comfortable enough
to have a real conversation that
actually could have a deep and
meaningful impact with your child
and somebody else will have that
conversation oh yeah and not a healthy
way no no they're gonna find something
online or one of their friends is gonna
say something in an unhealthy
perspective on it the number of middle
schoolers we deal with sexting and i
mean it's there right it's there it's
there so your voice needs to be the
loudest voice
and you can only do that by actually
using it in difficult situations how do
you recommend somebody have that begin
if i don't know where to begin
just do it
like there's you're talking about
conversations yep just do it
like there's no other way to
i wish there was like a formula you know
i told you about frameworks like oh well
the first thing you do is you present
the no yeah what you just do it and
you're gonna get better at it and so
before today i would have used the word
vulnerable and you may have used humble
humility what's vulnerable about well i
think what i well i'm getting is i think
below that i'm gonna be honest that's
and i like that and honest with my son
might be
hey i'm we're gonna have an awkward
conversation and i'm not gonna be great
at it but i've got to be the guy that
talks to you about this yes that's the
way to start that's just being truthful
it's being honest yes and letting them
know there's not a perfect way to do
this and yes you're probably gonna you
may have to go to counseling or you're
gonna be telling this joke with a couple
of buddies in your beers
when you're in college but we're doing
this today and you know what he's gonna
look fondly on absolutely because you
were honest with him well and here's
another example that i use is you know
occasionally my wife will come in with
the new pair of jeans on her new dress
or something
and and she'll say what do you think
so what do you say yeah do you tell her
if you don't particularly like that
let's say
uh or you don't think it looks that
great do you lie or do you tell the
truth
i tell the truth i would yeah why
wouldn't you yeah that was a tactical
way to do it what i usually say is if
something i say you know that one's not
as flattering as the other one that you
bought yeah
okay but you got to tell the truth
because if you do
on these seemingly insignificant
situations then when it really matters
she knows you're not full of crap well
and more importantly when your kids are
around they
i i believe one day when we've got
special radar sensors kids can obs they
feel dishonesty they know when you're
not telling the truth they know
everybody does
i agree with you
and when that you when mom doesn't comes
in with a dress and they know that
you're they whether it's minuscule eye
movements or what it is they know and if
they see you lie
they go that's how you do that right
that's the model right you don't tell
the truth if it's gonna be hard right or
i can respectfully say
man that last dress you have is
incredible this one's not as flattering
um you still look beautiful let's get
out of here right let's go exactly they
get a model for oh that's what love
looks like that's what that's what
honesty looks like that's what respect
and dignity looked like right and that's
again i would have used vulnerability
that's just what honesty looks like her
saying
i'm asking you
to be honest with me she wants your
opinion you being on us back yeah you
don't want my opinion don't ask me yeah
there you go yeah but we always laugh
because there's the old adage of you
know you know how you tell a true friend
is you know somebody will tell you if
you have a piece of toilet paper or
whatever stuck or there's something like
stuck on your face or a boogers hanging
down you know like a true friend will
say that we laugh about that but that's
actually true it's 100 true like they're
willing
and in a silly situation they're willing
to make themselves uncomfortable enough
because it's like bro you got a little
that's uncomfortable for me right but
i'm willing to do that because i care
enough about you to do it yes and the
the furthest extreme of that is i had a
buddy a couple of buddies
man this is 15 years ago 16 years ago um
i'd moved to a new town my wife was
gonna trail six months later she was
finishing some research up and
we were
hanging out and i made some i was just
trying to make an ill joke dude i was
just trying to be lame bro what's up
bros yeah and i said something along the
lines of
by the way in this new town man like
like where's the like i if i ever need a
girlfriend or something whatever and one
guy he's one of my closest friends to
this day his name's kevin he said hey
you don't know us that well so just so
we can go ahead and set the record
straight if you ever cheat on your wife
you better hope to god she finds you
before we do really and that was just
how we're laying this sucker out right
but that's and he's one of my that's the
way he lives his life is i don't know
you that well yeah i'm not going to
compromise who i am my values my purpose
for some you know i mean for some dude i
don't know so just so we're clear right
and there was an integrity there and
they would have put me in the hospital
and they would have sat with me you know
what i mean they would have they would
have brought a 30 pack and hung out in
the hospital with me and
that's
that's the kind of guys they are but it
goes back to
i'm gonna tell you the truth i'm gonna
be honest with you well and you said
integrity because they could probably
kick kick your ass like they said yeah
but there's also a low bar but there's
there's also in he also has integrity
because no man without integrity would
be able to say that
that's right like he he his words and
his thoughts are in alignment with his
action and so it gives him the
confidence which is earned to be able to
say something that is
confrontational yeah yeah yeah you know
and
another beautiful part of that is i get
to choose whether it's confrontational
or not
and i chose to hear it as a
it's a bad joke i would never do i mean
i i wasn't even a
it wasn't even me fishing it was uh me
trying to do water cooler joking my
wife's expense and that's a that's a
piss-poor way to be a grown man
and to show respect for my wife number
two
he called me out i needed to hear that
yeah well done yeah and i think i get a
choice on how i hear other people and i
think we've lost that too you hurt my
feelings you're at my feelings no i'm
not going to give you permission to hurt
my feelings you made a statement you
don't like when we started you said i
think your your shorts your pants are
stupid you didn't say that
i get to choose what i was thinking
because they're not delta jeans
i ordered some they're like on backward
until
may of 2028. they're so busy golly dude
jocko get it together let's go now um no
they i think they'll be here in the next
couple weeks but
like i get to choose whether you hurt my
feelings or not i'm not going to give
that power away to just everybody yeah
i'm going to hold on to it
okay um we're gonna do let's take a
break and we're gonna come back and then
i'm gonna rapid fire some questions
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndalone.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right let's rapid fire i wrote some
questions down ready
ready um give me a sentence or two off
top of your head
this is so fair to unfair because i
wouldn't
i would know how to here we go i was
like just re any rant but like you're
going to give me a prompt right there
okay okay okay
men and intimacy
you want a sentence or two around now
um
that is tough
what is masculinity and intimacy how do
they work together
i think it's a connection okay intimacy
is a connection and it's a
representation of the way that you guys
feel about each other the commitment
that you have towards each other
uh and your willingness to express it in
a healthy way that cares about her just
as much as it cares about you can you be
intimate with
people non-romantically for sure yeah
yeah i mean there's there's intimate
connections that aren't sexual yeah
right 100
okay
uh men and dependents
men and independents men and dependents
oh dependents yeah yeah you gotta you
gotta eliminate that from your life
dependence okay yeah you can't be
dependent on other people and other
things to solve all your problems and to
cover and provide for everything that
you need yeah i wrote i wrote a book
called sovereignty in 2017 2018 called
sovereignty
[Music]
it's independence that's what you should
be working towards not dependence on
other things in other people all right
next show we'll talk about that that'd
be great let's do it masculinity and
sexuality
there's a lot of immaturity around that
thought yeah um
as i was talking with my son the other
day about
sexuality and sexual and
body parts and things like that you know
he giggles and stuff but grown men don't
grow up
it's still funny grow out of it yeah you
know so i think there's a level of
maturity that needs to happen there so
that you can understand that
being sexual
having sex is
natural and healthy and good yeah and we
need to have healthy conversations and
discussions around it men and mental
health
i think that one's misunderstood tell me
about it i think a lot of times people
believe that if a man takes care of his
mental health whether that's going to
see a therapist or meditating or any
practice that could improve his mental
health
uh that he's somehow less manly which is
really a weird thing to consider to get
there that's i don't know i don't i
don't know i don't know why that's a
sign of weakness i mean we we talk about
building our mental fortitude
we talk about building our physical body
and presence and then if somebody goes
and uses a tool to help them work
through some
some mentality stuff some mindset stuff
or their emotions is another one then
somehow they're looked at as less manly
i actually think getting help and taking
care of your mind is
going to help you become more of a man
than not doing it so i it's been my
experience
i would rather do rounds with maybe not
now i'm not i'm not who i once was
i would i would have rather do rounds
with
professional fighters than go sit with a
trauma therapist those are hard um if
you go do that right there's a there's a
there's a
there's a fortitude necessary for that
for sure i don't understand that i don't
get to take care of it but it is what it
is but you know let's not discount
fighting either no i think there's
something about
the kinetic energy i think it's very
necessary and you're also you're talking
about intimacy yeah you know when when
other men are pushing on each other and
and you're trying to hurt me and i'm
trying to hurt you in a controlled
environment you know we're learning from
each other we're connecting i'm getting
to know about you when i train jiu jitsu
i can know pretty quick about a person
the way they train with me yeah
absolutely you know
when somebody grabs you and it's kind of
like oh you're like okay this guy's a
little passive like i'm wondering what
is he afraid
um i made a mistake with a guy from
brazil one time and
they were helping me off the mat is that
where i woke up yeah man this guy's just
he's he's weak man well i felt right
into it right but there's a difference
between weak and meek right here you're
going so like you could you can roll the
guy who doesn't have to exert all of his
force against you but still you know
i learned still you know there's a
difference i learned real quick yeah
yeah what's the difference um
how do we integrate strength power
no you know i'm gonna back up okay
we may disagree on this one maybe not
man i think
tell me about feelings in men
this is one i talk about actually quite
a bit all right um you you can't absolve
yourselves of being emotional
like you can't who is this
yes right like yes how is how is a human
being not going to be emotional but
here's where we get it wrong so let's
say you're really pissed about something
yep
and uh maybe you ask me a question i
just get pissed and i like
like like slam the the wall
or i punch a hole in the wall which i've
done yep
we think that we did that because we're
angry
no no no those are different yes anger
response they're they're not the same
you didn't do that because you were
angry you did that because you didn't
know how to respond differently to the
anger that you have
so
um i look at it like um
like the uh the dashboard on your car
you're driving down the road you notice
that the fuel light comes on
do you do you like swerve off the road
and wrap your truck around the next
telephone pole that you see because
you're pissed yeah no you're like okay
something's wrong
that's the fuel gauge i guess i'd better
pull off and go to the gas station then
you go to the gas station you put the
gas in and then correct the problem get
back on the road and you're on about
your day
so emotions all of them there are no
negative emotions anger jealousy
resentment fear those aren't negative
they're supposed to teach you something
yeah like what what's your dashboard
telling you and then what are you gonna
do that goes back to man
i love that good there's a
feelings don't count get rid of them if
you have them you're weak or
let them drive and run everything right
and i think that's a vulnerability thing
both of those are illnesses yeah they're
just illnesses right it's just an
inappropriate way to deal with it yeah
dude so like if i'm happy i'm gonna be
happy if i'm mad like i i can be mad in
fact being mad to certain situations is
the approach
that's right like you should be mad
about that the gap between that and the
response that's right and i think the
more that we can focus on that gap i
feel this and now what yes because i
didn't hit a hole through the wall
because of my wife i hit hold the ball
because i chose to hit off that wall
yeah because i didn't have the tools to
do maybe you didn't even choose to do it
but you've you've ingrained that pattern
i chose not to do it i chose to not not
do it yeah how about that you may not
even make a conscious choice you may
have reacted so
long to certain stimulus that you're not
even choosing to do it anymore you're
just that's you that's become you you
need to rewire that that's right and
that's what i would say
once you recognize i want to stop this
now it's on you to choose not to do it
right
however far upstream you got to go all
right we got a hustle james is in my ear
here okay so
and i always make somehow i always make
james out to be the bad guy james is
incredible you're a great guy it's a new
year new new me is that how we're gonna
do that new year new me james just let
us roll man come on why are you gonna
interrupt
listen it's a good thing i was really
liking you ryan
um tell me about a time you've been
wrong
um
man
i mean like i'm saying never please say
never
i'm not struggling because there isn't
any i'm struggling because i don't know
which one to tell you
um
man i'm having a hard time coming up
with how about time you changed your
mind well even the even the whole toxic
masculinity conversation is one that you
know initially
i i failed to realize
it it wasn't as broad and in depth as it
is now about how
masculinity is neither good nor bad it's
how you utilize it gotcha um and also i
had a lot of misconceptions about what
was manly i i tend to look at masculine
things and think well that guy he drives
cars and he's with women and he's
strong and so he's a man well not
necessarily you know and so i've really
had to go deep into figuring out
i like that your definition of manliness
masculinity has transcended biology has
transcended
really action it's really a character
yeah masculinity is biological yeah but
manliness is something so much bigger
okay all right um favorite book um
i'm gonna read it next so you tell me
okay um
as a man thinketh actually no no let me
back up that's a good one yeah have you
read that as a man thank you by james
allen uh wild at heart is actually
probably my favorite book have you read
that yeah dude that was 20 years ago
yeah he came out he came through last
year he's amazing yeah yeah that book
changed my life huh okay so i would so
um i'll get it back out
yeah i would i cracked that one up open
every year um favorite band
uh i i actually don't listen to a lot of
music so
i know you're gonna ask me about music
you're a music guy right yeah
my favorite band none please say none
i just got an air of
none why would i waste time
listening to music flex dude that's so
great i listen to no music i listen to
no other man
you know actually there's there's
there's one that i really enjoy because
my son and i my oldest son so my oldest
he fulfills uh orders
uh in our store okay
and that's that's something he's been
doing for about three years
and whenever we're in there he all he
wants to listen to is george strait
dude my son is so stuck on 90's country
man yeah man in a crazy country joe
diffie radio dude um
dwight yoakam yes
man my son came out i was telling you
all about it a couple months ago he came
out he's like daddy you ever heard of
this guy named garth brooks and i was
like no son tell me tell me who is it
now yes god awesome so i'm i'm a big uh
george strait fan cody jinx i like like
a lot of cody jinx if i'm listening to
music country music
most of his stuff's a little darker but
i like that i'll check him out yeah i
like some good darkness it's a great
song
loud and heavy is what it's called okay
that's a song i really like his and then
something a little bit more upbeat is uh
granger smith you know granger smith
he's he contributes country music as
well he's a friend of mine man
check him out too yep everybody go check
out granger smith that's awesome all
right hey as we wrap up tell me about
iron tribe tell me about the order man
tell me about all the stuff you got
going on yeah so the podcast is the best
place yeah you know that's where you can
learn about everything we're doing
called order a man podcast wherever you
listen uh we've got the iron council
that you alluded to we've got gosh 1100
guys in there all working together
holding each other accountable we've got
assignments and challenges and calls and
just about everything else you can think
of uh and then we do some events
periodically we do a father-son event
we're thinking about bringing a
father-daughter event on this year and
then we do a big meeting
we'll have you out that'd be a blast i
think your daughter your daughter's a
little young yeah to come but your son's
the right just ready right in the middle
of it you'll be awesome let's make it
happen i would love love that thanks my
brother dude i just met you today i feel
like you're my best friend that's
awesome can i do it back it's awesome
and i'm grateful for you thanks for
coming to nashville and hanging out with
us thanks brother appreciate it all
right man okay
[Music]
hey so that was my conversation with
ryan mickler i hope you enjoyed our time
together listen if you want to hear more
interviews let me know go to
johndaloni.comask and just put it in the
forum put in that email hey i want to
hear more interviews
love talking to folks like ryan who
believe what
what they what they believe they're not
afraid to talk about it that i can
disagree with them and we can still be
friends we're gonna still end up hunting
together and i can't wait
and man he has some cool origin shoes
come on jocko send some boots we'll see
you soon on the dr john delona
show you